déminéralisé tout ça donc voilà donc ça
c'est déminéralisé et vous allez voir
ici c'était c'était en fait des parkings
et tout ça c'est vrai que donner un
nouveau visage au quartier populaire la
première ministre elliisabeth borne
s'était rendue ce vendredi 27 octobre à
Chantelou les vignes une déambulation à
la rencontre des habitants et des
commerçants avec des mesures pour
améliorer le quotidien des populations
mixtité sociale transition écologique ou
emploi au lendemain des annonces du
gouvernement sur la sécurité après les
émutes de cet été la mère chantelouvaise
partageait son enthousiasme un accent
particulier sera mis sur l'écologie avec
davantage d'investissements pour
notamment s'adapter au changement
climatique la transition énergétique qui
n'avait jamais été retenu comme priorité
dans nos quartiers alors que c'est
l'endroit où il fait le plus chaud en
été le plus Frid en hiver et que les
habitants ont eu des augmentations de
chargge considérable alors que c'est
c'est ceux dont on sait très bien qui
coûtent le moins cher qui sont les moins
pollueurs et qui mais par contre qui
n'ont pas la possibilité de gérer leurs
propres économies donc là 15 % du fond
vert sur nos quartiers c'est ce qu'on
avait demandé ça c'est une attention
particulière tendre vers le plein emploi
une phase de test sera menée dès 2024
pour lutter contre les pratiques
discriminatoires envers les populations
des quartiers populaires objectif
permettre un meilleur accès au stag ou à
l'embauche pour soutenir
l'entrepreneuriat davantage de moyens
seront alloués avec 456 millions d'euros
débloqué sur 4 ans c'est un peu le
fantasme de de l'habitant de banlieu qui
sait faire son auto-entreprise euh moi
je ne crois pas qu'à ça je crois à la
formation beaucoup à l'apprentissage
beaucoup et si on donne pas un zoom un
zoom extraordinaire sur formation et
l'apprentissage on ne développera pas la
la capacité des jeunes d'aller chercher
l'emploi où ils veulent avec une avec un
métier qu'ils ont rencontré par passion
au cours de sa visite ellisabeth borne a
aussi découvert le site de la future
cité éducative Simon veille de Chantelou
Lévin qui devrait voir le jour en 2025
école médiathèque et centre de loisir
rassemblé au sein d'un campus
pluridisciplinaire pour aider à la
réussite des enfants la première
ministre a annoncé le développement de
ce type de projet à d'autres communes
une façon de faire de l'éducation un le
contre les inégalités sociales